well happy birthday Jesus sorry your
party's so lame
she would like for Christmas little boy
I don't know I I didn't know you were
gonna ask me that wow what did you think
was going to happen I didn't know
nobody's ever let me sit on their lap
before just say some toys please
can you give me some choices because I
really don't want to mess up on this
list Kevin come on
what about if I tell you the things I
don't want okay dude get off get off
oh
god I didn't even get to tell you what I
wanted okay you know what you get you
get a thousand helium balloons attached
to you so Santa doesn't have to go
through this again
awesome cancel we're canceling it
no no no no we're gonna get fresh for
Halloween
we don't have the budget for another
party well then everybody will chip in
it'll be fine I honestly think you're
idealizing people here again Michael I
don't think that's gonna happen you know
what I'll pay for it I'll pay for the
party it doesn't matter this is way too
important people oh he's coming back and
this is the most important Christmas
party of my life let's go back to work
I don't ask for much for Christmas I
really don't
it's not like I am begging people to buy
me diamonds and brooch
pendants oh buy me something expensive
or I'm gonna kill myself that's not
I don't care about that all I want to be
is Santa
and if you want to take that away from
me fine
go ahead
but when you need my help because I am
ruining everything don't look at me
thank you
it's great
behold
Jesus Christ and I bring to you glad
Christmas Tidings I want to remind
everyone the true meaning of Christmas
those of you who wish to join me that's
great I am excited by that and those of
you who don't
but I never forget wow Michael this must
be obvious how wrong was this oh the
Antichrist okay you can't ow look you
cannot push religion oh but I can push
drugs in here is that what you're saying
well you have to pick one or the other
your choice pick your poison get back to
me in the meantime I am going to spread
my goodness all over this company
I got it we are going to turn secret
santa into Yankee Swap what is Yankee
Swap one person chooses a gift the next
person can either choose a gift or steal
that person's gift if your gift gets
stolen then you can steal someone else's
gift or choose a new gift I thought that
was called Nasty Christmas yeah we call
it white elephant well I call it fun why
are we doing this because it's better
because it's more special it sounds mean
Meredith
have you ever used alcohol to alter your
mood or deliberately change your state
of mind sure
do you sometimes have a drink to
celebrate a special occasion or Mark a
holiday obviously
have you ever under the influence of
alcohol question the teachings of the
Mormon church
where did you get this I got it on a
website that's not important I always
should contact some experts you don't
know what you're doing hey you know what
Toby one of my employees is undergoing a
crisis and I wish for just once you
would take my side on this
your job man
hey are you texting yeah because this is
kind of a drag alcohol is a drag yes
here's what I'd like to do I'd like to
go around the room and have us each
Express to Meredith how her alcoholism
has affected us
all begin this Christmas party is
perhaps the best Christmas party I have
ever been to but then you got so drunk
that we had to stop and do this
that's how your drinking affected me
anybody else another time when
Meredith's drinking affected you
come on people if we don't say anything
she's not going to get any better
yes Kevin
well Meredith there was that one time
that you bought movie tickets and then
you got too drunk to go
so you gave them to me and that was
really cool
that's you didn't
you weren't hurt by that yeah you said
affected by it thanks again okay no
that's not what we're going for that's
just from the Dunder Mifflin
Branch we don't have a North Pole branch
idiot oh what striking I guess what is
it
yes oh yes it's space garbage Dwight's
gonna be able to build himself a friend
dick calls with crap
been very good this year I have yeah
except for cheating on your wife adulter
is a sin look it up in the Bible people
what'd he get he got scented candles oh
well that's appropriate a lot of fire
where you're going better get used to it
you're going to hell double hockey
sticks going to hell Stanley amen and
this brings us to you little one
I can't see from here people somebody
shout it out don't make me get up
it's fabric
I really wanted this that's fantastic
you can make another dress that goes
past your feet Andy was this you it's a
secret
that Michael you what is that you're not
supposed to stay what turn it back on
what happened what happened
Toby what did you do I think Toby's very
jealous of all the attention you've been
getting you know I would never ever do
anything like that but it does seem like
something you would do oh really turn it
on me well isn't that nice thank you
very much wait wait guys listen
Toy Story is all about toys that come to
life when people aren't looking
you don't think
it's not possible
that Woody did this to himself it is
Christmas no it really seems like
something Michael would do um
the fact that you would think that
points to the possibility that is
probably not me and that I have been
framed why would anyone frame me for
that okay I'm sorry why are we
discounting this whole Woody came to
life thing so quickly
oh
[Laughter]
surprise that was part of the party
pretty funny huh you think this is funny
I don't
but someday I think we will laugh about
this
when we tell our kids
okay moving along Meredith let's go I
really want the iPod it's already been
stolen this round to pick something else
I hope nobody takes this baby because
this is great wow look at that fine
craftsmanship
and you really put a lot of work into
that it's beautiful
I'll take the oven mitt
see I wanted somebody to take it boom
reverse psychology
is this
that is my Christmas card it's a picture
of you and me and your kids on a ski
trip having a blast skeezing's greetings
no
I know
I went on a ski trip right two years ago
with my kids and my ex-husband yes but
what you didn't realize at the time was
that I was with you in a sense I was in
your heart and next to your kids what
this is so weird
I don't understand it's a bold move to
photoshop yourself into a picture with
your girlfriend and her kids on a ski
trip with a real father
but then again Michael's a bold guy
is bold the right word I think you're a
really sweet guy okay but um
I don't know how to deal with with like
this thing and and the proposal and I
don't think things are gonna work out
with us okay okay you know what you're
not thinking straight
you know you need you need
to think this through in
Jamaica's largest freshwater pool
what are you talking about I got us
tickets
two sandals Jamaica we leave Day After
Tomorrow you had better find the
skimpiest bikini oh there is Michael and
it's all inclusive
Michael yes
I'm sorry
no Carol you walk out that door and it
is over I know
foreign
like everybody's attention
Christmas is canceled you can't cancel a
holiday you get up Stanley and you will
lose New Year's what does that mean Jim
take New Year's away from Stanley
Michael what's going on
Carol and I
split up
amicably and I just don't think it would
be appropriate to celebrate under the
circus will they still air Rudolph
that's not fair are we going to cancel
Hanukkah as well
fine
have your party
just no guess but we invited guests well
you know what Phyllis
all of your guests would have probably
canceled at the last minute anyway
leaving your life a stupid rotten mess